hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve a pretty
difficult problem median of two sorted
arrays
so we're given two arrays nums one and
nums two that are already
in sorted order but they could be of
different sizes
m and n and we want to return the median
of both of the arrays when they have
been put together
and sorted so not individually but we
want to put them together and then find
the median of both of them
and not only that but we want to do it
efficiently so log of m
plus n worst case right so
one example we can see one array could
be one
three another array could be two and in
this case
when you put the two arrays together
it's pretty obvious that
two is the median that the median is the
middle value
now we know that there are other
examples where we might have an even
number of total elements
one two three four when you put those
together
we get one two three four in this case
we have
two numbers that are in the middle two
and three so what do we do we can just
take the average
of these two and we know the average is
2.5
but both of these examples used a
merged array but we know if we actually
merged
two arrays together like one two and
three four
the worst case is actually big o n plus
m and that's not log
so we know in most cases when people
want a
log algorithm you need binary search and
that's exactly what i'm going to show
you right now how to solve this problem
with binary search so let's say we are
given a different example let's call
this array b
and let's call this array a so we know
we can
merge these two arrays right and then
the median is obvious but what exactly
is a median well it's the middle
value right in this case this is the
middle value
and we know that because we know to the
left of it
there are six elements and to the right
of it
there are six elements so in this case
we have a
array of 13 elements and this happens
to be the middle the left partition
of six elements is the same size as the
right partition of six elements so what
we're doing
is partitioning the array into two equal
halves
roughly right because we know there's an
odd case and an even case
now let's just take hypothetically this
eight doesn't exist
then in reality we have 12 elements so
we take the left partition to be six
elements and the right partition to be
six elements
so in that case we know we can take the
two
middle most elements or in other words
the right most value in
our left partition and the leftmost
value
in our right partition and take the
average so add them together
and divide by two we know that's going
to be 3.5
so how can we simulate that without
actually
merging these two arrays how can we
simulate that with just
the original arrays which are still in
sorted order right
luckily for us they are given in sorted
order so keep in mind that the total
number of elements we have
in this case is 13 and half the number
of elements we have
is roughly six i'm going to round down
in this case and when we talk about
partitioning we want our
left partition to be roughly equal
to half so when we partition this
we want the left to be roughly 6. so the
most intuitive way to do this
is let's get half of the elements of
let's say
a right so i'm going to have a left
pointer initialized here and i'm going
to have a right pointer initialized
here and i'm gonna find the middle so we
know this is index zero this is index
four i add them together on average
so we know that the middle is gonna be
two right so what are we actually gonna
do
so this is going to be our middle value
right
and basically what that means is our
left partition is going to include that
so so far our left partition
initially is going to be like this now
obviously we can increase it by adding
an element
we can also decrease it by removing an
element
but initially let's have our left
partition have
three values in it so it has three
values great now can we repeat that same
process
up here well the good thing is we don't
actually need to because look in this
case if we do that we're gonna get
four and we can basic if we want we can
run binary search up here too but is
that even necessary because
look at this half our elements are
six so really what we can do is say half
minus three over here
is going to be equal to three so if we
run binary search on just
this bottom ray on this bottom array we
can
compute the size of the left partition
for the second
array right we can just compute it using
our half
value and since we know 6 minus three is
three we know initially we can say that
the left partition of this
is gonna be three as well we don't even
need to keep
a left and right pointer for this array
so these two
uh sub arrays make up our left partition
now my question is how do we
know if we found the correct left
partition or not
well we want them to be in order right
so notice how we already know that this
3 is going to be
less than or equal to the element that
comes after it that's what sorted order
means
and we already know this value is going
to be less than or equal
to the value to the right of it because
this is also in sorted order
but we want to make sure that the left
partition
is less than or equal to every
element in the right partition and this
is our right partition so
how can we determine that well one thing
we can ask
is is this is the right most
element in this part of the partition
less than or
equal to this value
and in this case it is we also want to
ask
is this value less than or equal
to the left most value in
this part of the partition in the right
partition
is it less than or equal to that in this
case
it is and what this tells us is that
our left partition has been done
correctly
and if it's not clear enough let me just
write it out again so remember if we
merge these two arrays this is what it's
going to look like
and our left partition is going to be
this right we have 13 elements this is
our left partition
and we can say that this is our right
partition
but since it's odd we can add that extra
element
and you can see that that's exactly what
we found here right
okay so we know we found the left
partition correctly right so the left
is going to be this sixth element but
how do we find that middle value
well in this case either of these two is
a
four so either of them is going to be
the median right we have two fours
either of them could be the median but
hypothetically let's say
one of these was a five so let's say
maybe in the top
we had a 5 so this would be a 5.
how would we find the median in that
case well
from these two values right we know one
of them has to be the median
what we would do is take the minimum of
both of them
so we take the minimum of the leftmost
values in both partitions so
so the min of 5 and 4 and we know that's
going to be
4 so 4 is our median so this example was
a little too
easy because we didn't actually really
need to run a search
so let's remove one element and let's
update our total
to 12 now instead of 13 because we just
removed one
the half is still going to be six so now
let's do the same thing our right
pointer is going to be here
this is index zero this is index three
we divide three by two
we're going to round down to one so
this is going to be our middle position
and what that tells us is our left
partition
is going to be like this and now how do
we get the left partition
of this well similarly we can take 6
minus 2 which is the size of our left
partition so we get four so the left
partition
of this is going to be of size four we
take the first
four elements so now let's check do we
have our left partition correctly have
we done it correctly how can we check
that well let's check that this
2 is less than or equal to the 5. we
know that's true
right 2 is less than 5. what about this
value
is the rightmost value in this partition
less than or equal to this
it's not right four is not less than or
equal to three that's just not true
so our left partition is not correct in
this case right how can our left
partition
have a 4 where our right partition
has a 3 that means we have not
partitioned it correctly
so what that tells us is we have to
update these pointers right because we
are doing binary search
so initially our left our middle was
over here so what we're going to do
is take our left pointer and then shift
it
one plus the middle value the old middle
value because we know
that we're going to need extra elements
from array
a so with our left shifted over here
we're going to recompute the middle we
know the index of this is 2
this is 3 we add them together 2 plus
3 divided by 2 if we round down is going
to be 2. so what's going to end up
happening
is our left partition is now going to be
these three elements because mid is
going to be over here
and so how many elements from our array
b
are we going to need well let's just
compute it right half is 6
minus 3 because that's the size of this
partition
is going to total to be 3 so we know
that the partition from
b is also going to be need to be size
three
so let's get the first three elements of
this now let's
check have we partitioned our
left have we partitioned this correctly
so let's check
is this three less than or equal
to this value yes it is three is less
than four
is this three less than or equal
to this value yes three is less than or
equal to four
so that tells us we finally partitioned
our our arrays correctly but you saw
originally we had 13 elements so it was
odd and when it's odd in that case what
we had to do was take the minimum
of these two values right but in this
case it's even so what are we actually
going to do now
so how are we going to find the median
well how would we do it if we had a
sorted array so this is
how the sorted array would look if we
merged these two
right and we can see that look at our
left partition we have one
two and three right so this is our left
partition right now
right it's size six this is our
right partition it's also size
six so clearly if we actually want to
find the median what we have to do is
take
the max value from
our left partition and take the minimum
value
from our right partition right like
that's
pretty obvious so how do we translate
that when we actually have
two separate arrays how do we actually
translate that let me show you
well we can take the minimum of
these two values right and in this case
they're clearly
the same but if they were different we
would want to take the minimum
of both of them right and we would want
to take
the max of these two values
of that and this right in this case
they're
also the same but they could be
different hypothetically so we would
take
that right and that's going to get us
the two values we need to compute the
median and of course we can just divide
them
by two so this is the main
idea of this algorithm you can see that
it's actually
somewhat intuitive once you understand
some of the basic ideas
let me just show you one last thing
that's gonna make the code a lot
easier for us hypothetically our left
partition
from this array right a hypothetically
it could be
one it could also be zero right we want
our left partition to be six elements
what if we just took
the six elements from over here that's
gonna make edge cases a little annoying
like you know how we always wanna make
sure that
the value from over here is less than or
equal
to that and we wanna make sure that this
is going to be less than or equal to
something like this but if we had 0
values here
i'm going to basically default that like
there's
a positive infinity over here and
there's a negative infinity over here
so that if we wanted all elements to
come from a single array we would
actually be checking okay is this less
than or equal to the positive infinity
and i'm going to show you basically what
i mean in the code but i hope that the
main idea
of what we're doing the binary search to
find the median
is at least somewhat obvious now so we
have two
arrays nums one and nums two i'm going
to assign them
two different variables we'll call them
a and b
and you know how we only have to run
binary search on one of them i'm gonna
make sure that we run binary search on a
and i'm gonna make sure that a
is the smaller of these two arrays
so we'll check if the length of a is
bigger than b
then we're gonna we're gonna swap these
two uh
arrays we're gonna swap a and b so let's
also
get the total and half length of
each of these so the total is just gonna
be the length of each
added together and half is just going to
be
total divided by 2. in python we need
the double if we want to do integer
division so now i'm going to run binary
search on
a because a is the smaller so the left
and right pointers are going to be
zero and length of a minus one
and remember that half is going to tell
us the total elements
in the left partition so now i'm just
gonna be
lazy and say while true we're going to
start
looping we're going to run our binary
search because we know that there's
guaranteed a minimum so once we
are there's guaranteed a median so once
we find it we can just return
it so now of course we want to compute
the middle value
of array a that we're gonna use to get
our left partition
so we're gonna take left and right
pointers add them together
divide by two now how do we get the
and so this is referring to a so we'll
call this
this is for a this is the pointer for b
now
we don't actually need to divide
anything by two we can just take half
and subtract i from it but one thing
you need to know that this is going to
be the index
so to get rid of the off by one errors
j is not actually the number of elements
in array b it's actually the index of
the midpoint so we're going to take
subtract i and we're also going to
subtract 2 from it because we know
arrays are indexed at zero
and we're doing this because we know j
starts at zero and i starts at zero so
we gotta do the extra minus by two
so now we wanna get the values
right the values that we're actually
gonna need to compare to find
to determine if we actually found the
median right if we actually have a
correct
left partition so you know we can take
a left to be a of index i right
that's going to be the value in the left
partition that we're going to need to
use to compare
and there's also going to be a value in
the right partition of
of a right and we know it's adjacent
right so what we can do is just take
i plus one and we can repeat this with b
right so b left is going to be b at
index j
b right is going to be b at
index j plus one but here's the part
where i'm gonna make our lives a lot
easier and avoid some edge cases now any
of these
indices technically could be out of
bounds right
isn't that true so if i is out of bounds
hypothetically what would that mean that
would mean i
is less than zero so if i is less than
zero is there a default value that we
can give to a
left there is and it's called
negative infinity right so it's going to
be set to a of i
if i is greater than or equal to zero so
if i
is still in bounds set it to the value
at this position if it's not let's
default
the default value we can give this is
negative
infinity and we can do the exact same
thing for this one
if this j is actually out of bounds it's
going to be that
j is less than or equal is basically
less than zero so it's gone too far to
the left
so if j is greater than or equal to zero
leave it as it is
otherwise set this to negative infinity
and what about this value if i plus
1 is out of bounds that must mean we
want
all the values in array a to be a part
of our left partition so if i
plus 1 is out of bounds the default
value
that means that the default value we
want to give it is infinity
because we've gone too far to the right
and otherwise if
i is less than length
of a then we will leave it as it is
or i plus 1 rather right we're checking
if i plus 1
is out of bounds and we're going to do
the exact same thing for
b so if j plus 1 is within bounds
we can leave it as it is get b of j plus
otherwise we're going to set it to
positive infinity
so now finally with these you'll see
that we've actually just done
the algorithm now our life is so easy
we can check if a left is
less than or equal to b right
because that's what we were doing in the
picture right
if that's true and if b left
is less than or equal to a right
that means our left partition is correct
so we found the median but remember
there's two cases
there's one case that we have an odd
number of elements so how do we know if
we have an odd number we can take the
total number
mod it by two if this equals one
then we have to compute the median
odd so if you remember from the picture
we can get that by taking
the minimum of a right
and b right we can take the minimum of
these two values
and return it notice how if one of these
values
is an actual real number let's say four
and one of them
is positive infinity we're going to take
the minimum of these two so we're going
to end up returning
4. now both of these will never be
infinity you can run through some
examples to prove that to yourself
and if it's not odd that means it's even
length
so how can we get the median in that
case
well we take the max of
a left and b left just like we did in
the picture
we add that to the minimum of
a right and b right so these are going
to be the two
values in the middle and we can divide
them
by two we want decimal division in this
case
and then we can return that value so now
in the case that we
don't find the median it could be
possible that a
left is greater than b
right like that's a possibility right
and in that case
basically that tells us that a left is
too big so we have
too many elements from a so we're going
to reduce the size of a
so what we can do is take our right
pointer
and shift it to i minus one so we're
reducing the size of the left partition
from a and the third case is just the
else case
where it would be that this condition
was not true
in that case we would need to increase
the size of our left partition from a
so we would say left is equal to
i plus 1. and that's actually the entire
code so we don't need a return statement
outside because we know
that our loop is eventually going to
find a median and we're going to return
it whether it's odd
or whether it's even so you can see we
did this in about 30 lines of code
and it would probably be less if i
removed some of the spaces in the
comments
and the time complexity is basically
going to be
log of the minimum of n
of n or m because we're running binary
search on the smaller of the two
and as you can see it's a pretty
efficient solution
and i really hope that this was helpful
to understand
like the big picture it's a difficult
problem i probably wouldn't be able to
figure this out on my own but you can
see it
is definitely understandable once you
know some of the tricks behind it
don't forget to like and subscribe if
this was helpful it supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon